that's the car only maroon yeah
beautiful vehicle i like that i like
that too now to our coverage of women's
history month and this morning
we're looking at the impact of the
pandemic on women and work
nearly three million women have left the
workforce during the pandemic among
working mothers a survey shows
that two in five have taken a step back
from work or at least are considering it
many cite child care as a reason tammy
birch she is from chinook kansas is one
of them
she's a single mother who says she had
no option but to leave her job because
she could not afford child care for her
two children after school
[Music]
it was the scariest thing i've ever done
to leave my job before the pandemic
tammy burch was able to bring her
ten-year-old twins to the assistant
living facility
where she worked i had to quit because
the facility went on lockdown
i couldn't bring my kids to work anymore
i didn't have anybody for child care
so of course i had to stay home with
them i've looked for
temporary jobs online where i could work
from home but
there really isn't anything around here
that i can do without
a college degree
received unemployment benefits for
several months but they ended abruptly
last
october she was told her account was
flagged for fraud
and provided all requested documents
tammy says the kansas department of
labor told her in january
she still qualifies for benefits that
they are sorting it out
but she has still not received any new
unemployment checks
i spend a good three four hours on the
phone every day if not more
i have no money i have zero dollars with
no income or
savings birch is now ten thousand
dollars in debt
it's hard for me to keep a smile on my
face and to tell them everything's gonna
be okay when i'm not sure myself
burch continues to look for a job where
she can work from home
but she doesn't know what the future
holds i think it's going to take
quite a bit of time to recover from this
it's going to be building from ground
zero
for me after cbs news contacted the
kansas department of labor
it called tammy and told her it has now
filed all of her claims
which now paves the way for her to get
all the money joining us now is some
financial advisors for women
financial advice is what she's trying to
say for women like tammy
the cbs news business analyst that's
jill schlesinger good morning to you
jill
so good morning what's the best use of
the money do you think for people who
are in the situation that tammy is in
you know i think about these women who
are really struggling and i say the most
important thing you can do
is save any money and we know that big
checks are going to start flowing in
1400 stimulus checks child care tax
credits
that money money's going to come in so
do what most americans have been doing
with their excess
cash they've been saving it last month
gail we saw the savings rate pop
up over 20 percent you wind the clock
back
maybe 10 15 years nobody was saving a
dime
so please save save save before you
start paying those bills
make it really safe sometimes it's so
hard to save joe when you don't have the
money to save so i'm looking at women
who are
thinking about leaving the job or
considering it at some point
what do you think they should be
thinking about financially
i think that the best uh plan of action
is to really detail
what your expenses are so this can
happen suddenly we know that so even if
you have a job
you really should be looking at what are
my essential things that i have to pay
and you know what's essential food
everything else is negotiable
but you know the categories include food
and shelter and utilities
you heard tammy say she accumulated debt
a lot of people will get some money
maybe from unemployment they'll think i
should pay down my debt
no you need to keep that money safe and
you're really looking at food first
everything else is negotiable and
remember you can never hide
in a situation where you've lost your
job suddenly you've got to notify
every single person that's out there
whether you owe money to them
a utility provider a landlord get on the
record and say
covid has impacted my life and this is
whether you leave voluntarily or
involuntarily
remember tami's is actually really
classified as an
as a voluntary but she doesn't feel that
way she had no one to take care of her
kids
so she has to really notify everyone out
there
obviously jill people are really worried
about health care in this pandemic if
you've lost your job what are your
health care options
well you know with this new bill that
was just passed
i want people to pay attention to the
affordable care act for the next two
years
premiums are capped at eight and a half
percent of your modified adjusted gross
income
that means way more people are going to
qualify for the affordable care act
also remember you'll get more tax
credits there is of course
medicaid if you need it and as we know
there is cobra
cobra is existing coverage which the
government will pay for from a